we were hearing from the parents of a 14
year old teenager who was allegedly
attacked by a woman
in a new york hotel and then wrongly
accused of taking her phone
jazz musician keon harrell recorded this
video of mia poncetto approaching
his son keon harold jr and then falsely
accusing him of stealing the phone
surveillance video later shows her
tackle the teenager to the ground
poncetto now faces a series of charges
including attempted assault
in an exclusive interview she told us
she is sorry we asked the teen's parents
how he's coping with this very traumatic
incident and for their reaction to her
apology
and arrest i'm happy that she's
been arrested but that's only the first
step
in a very big conversation that needs to
happen
here in america that has to do with
racial profiling
if i had done that what my pensada
done to my son i'd be in jail now
if i had hurt her in any way i'd be in
jail now we wouldn't even be able to
have this conversation
as a black man every day i walk outside
i have to play the perfect game
almost like throwing a no-hitter just to
be believed
no no you can't no i'm the manager of
the hotel i don't care
this is my son the hotel has said keon
that they believe that it should have
been handled differently
i'm so angry i'm so angry at that hotel
because this this could have been
de-escalated
this could have been de-escalated a long
time ago we talked to mia poncetto who
says
i am puerto rican this was not racial
profiling
i just really panicked because i didn't
have my phone
she says race had nothing to do with
this particular incident
and certainly had nothing to do with her
targeting your son
what do you think when you hear that no
one has to say the n word for something
to be an
act of racism keon you must have been
stunned when you stepped off the
elevator with your son
i'm still in shock gail i'm still in
shock at this point
i work as hard as i possibly can just to
put my son
in the best scenarios to give him a
chance to win to give him a chance to be
a whole
young man a whole young boy black boy
we've been
all over the world and for to be in our
beloved new york city and this happened
i'm appalled i am not asking you to
justify your behavior or defend yourself
against her please know that
but her version is that you know i was
grabbed
pushing her away to protect my son
yes i'm a man who don't believe in
hurting women first of all
second of all i do believe in protecting
my son
so that is what i did what do you all
feel or what do you make of her apology
listen i
feel like her apology was
you know as genuine as
when she shushed you you're 22. i
killed it enough it said a lot
i have an issue with the idea of
entitlement versus character
well said it's all been tragically
consistent i'll just say that
yeah i apologize can we move on
those were the exact words that she used
with you does that sound like an apology
she knew she assaulted a 14 year old boy
not a guy not a man keon jr comes from a
musical family
his mother is a singer and a saxophonist
for beyonce
his father is a grammy award-winning
trumpeter they say they are using music
to help their son heal from this
incident
[Music]
keon jr wrote a song called unjustified
times and he recorded it with friends
while he played the drums
cat i'd like to know how he's doing when
i went to hug him
from behind because i i just i i
you know we we have such a great
relationship
he said mom he tensed up he literally
turns up
said mom can i ask you not to do that
it i can't i can't
i can't why did he ask you not to do
that
because this young lady which i will not
say her name
she does not deserve that this young
lady
blindsided him in the hotel he keeps on
asking the question
why like why me mom you know i wouldn't
steal anything i didn't know her
why as a mother
to have to answer that question
it's tough to look in
her being arrested more than what it is
because the person who killed trayvon
martin
is free the person who blamed emmett
till
is still alive things could have gone
another way what does justice look like
for your family
at this point for the both of you
justice
i think the idea of justice just like
the idea of the apology
is so much more than just saying i'm
sorry because people can say i'm sorry
and it's empty
justice has to do with change
yeah my heart really went out to them
because you can still feel the pain you
can still know that their son
is still very shattered they said he
can't even look at his phone anymore
because there's so much information that
comes you know
this he's in therapy his family has him
in therapy and you know there's
they're both still traumatized too still
reeling from it ben crump represents him
and saying you know
they hope that the charges it will send
a message that just because this woman
who appeared to be a white woman she's
now saying she's puerto rican was
believed
over the word of the people of the
father and son who said look we didn't
do this
and she's right that it could have been
de-escalated you know on the tape you
can hear keon senior saying you know
do the iphone feature do the iphone find
my iphone
feature it would have solved it just
right then and there yeah well and if
you lose your phone do you go up to some
random person and attack them no
now i don't intend to start doing that
no i don't i don't think that's there's
there's so many layers of wrong here in
this case there are no winners here
there are none